welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar cannabis based
therapeutics indication formulation and
route of administration it is presented
by Guillermo Moreno sans PhD founder and
CSO of a began a research my name is
Judy O'Rourke and I'll be your moderator
for today's events we're delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots leverets is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email following the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Marie no sense
I will now turn the presentation over to
him Thank You uni for the introduction
thank you everybody
it's a pleasure for me to give here this
presentation of lab roots and what I'm
going to talk about today is about
therapeutic products there are based on
cannabis or cannabinoids have been
approved by regulatory agency either the
FDA or the year or the EMA the European
medicine agents and then we'll talk a
little bit a little bit investigate a
little bit about the indications that
are either approved or recommended for
cannabis and cannabinoids different
formulations that we can use if we can
find in the market to exploit this
pharmaceutical action of cannabis or
cannabinoids and then
how different routes of administration
might be preferred
depending on the indication and the
formulation of cannabis and cannabinoids
that we want to use so basically what
I'm gonna do it's a brief introduction
to the therapeutic use of cannabis we'll
see examples of pharmaceutical drugs
that have been approved by regulatory
agencies what clinical indications exist
now therefore canvassing cannabinoids
and the routes of administration as I
was mentioning briefly introducing my
company is called a Bakula research we
are located in the north of Spain in the
Basque Country and it's my scientific
initiative after years of working in
academia in particular at the University
of California in Irvine what we realize
is that companies operating in the US
are having difficulties working with
their local universities because the you
operate under state law while a
university is generally federally funded
so the table is the opportunity for
industry leaders to have scientific
consultation also externalize their
research services and we specialize also
on product development
so basically cannabis and cannabinoids
can i knowit's are a family of molecules
that exists on the plant cannabis sativa
and are exclusive to this plant we
normally the cannabinoids are
synthesized in the flower or in the
trichomes of the flowers and bracts and
Konami know it's our half one molecular
precursor cone can I be ironic acid that
can be converted into ta-ta or
tetrahydrocannabinol castle or CBD a
konami no cannabidiol ik acid that upon
healing by not in somatic
decarboxylation like in the open when
you bake them or when you smoke them are
converted to the neural force that we
all know THC tetrahydrocannabinol or
cannabidiol
the main cannabinoids that
novena cannabidiol sorry
tetrahydrocannabinol and cannabidiol are
depicted in this slide TC it's a partial
agonist of type 1 and type 2 cannabinoid
receptors or cb1 and cb2 as they are
also known the activation of central cv
1 the cb1 receptors that we have in our
brains is responsible for the foreign
effects of THC or what is commonly known
as the high of THC and has several
reported effects as a logistic anti
planetory appetite stimulant sedating
antiemetic and antitumoral among others
CBD has been described as an allosteric
modulator for cv 1 and cb2 that's the
reason why one CVD it's psychoactive
because I have some reporting effects
such as al silly dick or anti-psychotic
which are exerted by the action of CVD
in the brain it is not overly a
fluorescent so it won't get you high
other pharmaceutical actions for CVD
that have been described are Sally
hibbe-dah for fact EVD which is
responsible for the degradation of the
endocannabinoid Amanda mine were also as
an agonist for the receptors v HC one a
sentinel receptors unbundle with
receptors 51
it also inhibits something else in the
activation so here we can see the
reported effects for CVD the most
well-known or the best known as anti
compulsive anton
recently approved by fda in the
presentation of epidemics for
Dramat syndrome and in august of
pediatric epilepsy basically the target
of THC and the endocannabinoids
which are naturally occurring molecules
in our body and our brains the target
for this molecule is called the
endocannabinoid system and is composed
by some of the players or animation such
as cannabinoid receptor cb1 and cb2 the
ends and the ligands that activate them
a data mine and to a key
the incense responsible for the
synthesis and degradation of these
ligands basically as part of my PhD
dissertation this is work that has been
done at the University of California in
Iran and published in 2010 in Nature
Geoscience we discover or characterize
how activation of peripheral cb1
receptors that is cannabinoid receptors
are outside the brain was sufficient to
elicit cannabinoid mediated analgesia
meaning that for pain management or the
lease zone I mean some force of pain
management we could technically use we
could technically activated only
cannabinoid receptors outside of our
brain we will have equal efficacy as
what we do generally I want to introduce
a couple of concepts basic
pharmacokinetic parameters that will be
useful for the rest of my talk so
basically what we're talking about a
drug that we intake the parameters that
we meet together we we care about is how
this drug will increase its
concentration in our blood right you see
how it goes up until it reaches see max
which is the maximum concentration that
after a single intake we will have in
our plan of this particular tract and
then we have a face this is a face of
absorption and then we have a face of
elimination in which the drug
concentration in the blood decreases in
between this range that we call the
therapeutic range meaning and it's
composed by the minimum concentration of
the drug in the plant that we need to
actually feel an effect or to have an
effect and then the minimum
concentration that starts to be toxic on
hit the gates of cannabis hold it or THC
a particular starts to be discomfort in
causing overly psycho activity or even
some other adverse effects like such as
dizziness or
somnolence and this will be the
therapeutic range the range of
concentration in the blood in which we
have efficacy and we have the very game
without any side effects
the T Max is the the time that takes for
the drug to reach the maximum
concentration in the blood and the time
to answer mean means how long does it
take for the drug to reach meaning
unaffected concentration so how long
does it last between we intake the drug
and we feel the first effects
so traditionally cannabis has been
normally smoked even NIDA used to
distribute joints to patients the
viability of THC depends on the way of
smoking maybe you will take long draws
or shorter drug how I don't know other
particulars of your smoking device and
it's considered a very rapid run of
administration at the time for the
maximum concentration of THC in the
blood is nine minutes and this allows
the spirit user to better titrate the
doses by taking more or less hits you
know the immediacy of the of the effect
allows you to understand if you need
another dosing or not the problem with
the smoking is that as you can see here
the concentration in the blood goes over
a hundred nano grams per ml really fast
so a hundred nano grams per ml it's more
or less what is considered the
concentration of THC in the in the blood
after which you will have psycho
activity or you will be high however
this is the the preferred route of
administration for many users experience
especially experience experience ones
that can you know depending on the way
of smoking control the amount of THC
that gets to the bloodstream and
therefore the efficacy of the treatment
so very briefly for mature
pharmaceutical drugs based on cannabis
and Konami
that have been approved by different
regulatory agencies we have Maryknoll
which is dronabinol which is a synthetic
form of THC now this molecule is exactly
the same as the THC that you will have
in the plant but it has been synthesized
in a lab that allows it not to be a
skill among drug license but a skill
free drug sorry spell as it'll three
substance and therefore its use is much
less restricted by the DEA
so marginal are coming a presentation of
soft gel caps containing two point five
five four ten milligrams of THC
excipients are pretty common getting
listen sesame oil any percents and this
is why I want to point out these
characteristics about approved drugs
it presents high inter-individual
variability high absorption but high
liver metabolism so ninety to
ninety-five is absorbed and only ten to
twenty percent gets the blood stream and
hyperbolic distribution with high
plasmatic problem finally what does this
mean is that THC doesn't like to be in
the water it likes to be fine in either
to protein or to a fatty tissue such as
the brain or your adipose tissue another
formulation of the rabinal the same t
synthetic THC is cinders this was a
profit to approve in 2016 by the FDA for
the indications of anorexia and OVA VIH
wasting syndrome and chemotherapy
related notion body so it has a liquid
presentation instead of a soft gel cap
it reduces inter inter-individual
variability but it still has a thorough
improperly glycol there is nothing fancy
about this appearance of this
formulation also but it reduces the
internal variability which is an
advantage over
paranal sesame is it's an analogue it's
this is a synthetic molecule that is
different in its structure from THC
but basically the the way of
administration is the same isn't just it
as a hard cup and the results are more
or less the same than 48c the only thing
is a it's a synthetic compound its
approval so for chemotherapy related
notion family and that is a skill to
control substance instead of a Schedule
three or skill one in case of natural
THC still adverse effects are sunless
dissonance and euphoria which are common
to cannabis and cannabinoids now we get
to a different set of approved compounds
or through pharmaceuticals which are
based actually on cannabinoids that come
from the plant they are not synthetic
the first one will be sativex which is a
sublingual spray that contains two point
seven milligrams of THC and two point
five milligrams of CBT per spray it see
fields again ethanol propylene glycol
and oil to give it a flavor and it's a
proof only and only for a specific
associations closest although there are
some clinical services that are using
them off indication for a particular
chronic and neuropathic pain the
difference is that it allows you to
control those impacts better and it's
absurd through the oral mucosa at least
partially so it has a more favorable
pharmacokinetic profile it's absurd
faster than if you will take only
through your stomach
finally epidemics is the is the medicine
that we mentioned before has been
approved by FDA for pediatric
excuse me for pediatric seizures being
the from head syndrome and the dagestan
again it's a transparent or less or LC
VD solution very very concentrated the
weekly doses can it has a period of
weekly dose escalation the same that we
see with all cannabinoid medication it
comes from five ten to twenty milligrams
milligrams per day and it because it's a
very very high concentration that has a
high dose of CBT it has some other
things such as liver damage Summerlin's
or suicidal thoughts so how does it
change how does the formulation change
how is it different to take Maryknoll
or syndromes when it's the same
synthetic THC well you here see the
difference when you take a capsule that
has to go through your stomach and get
out sorting to your intestine it's not
the same as stock taking something
that's written in liquid that it can be
much more paper favorably absorbed and
here you see that after 15 minutes in
all these volunteers that are all these
patients that took both formulations
hundred percent of those who talk
syndra's had already THC on their blood
and less than 25 percent of those who
take marginal had already it's in their
blood meaning that cinders is going to
have a much faster absorption that
Marinho and that's very important
especially for acute indication such as
acute pain or epilepsy which you need a
fast response also the intern dividual
variability is reduced in the in the
case of singulars compared to tomorrow
you see here 13.5 versus 36 is almost
half so another example for changing the
route of administration would be smoking
versus product like side effects so you
can hardly hear you see the the numbers
but basically when you smoke we talked
about those nine minutes that THC will
take to get into your blood we have data
from THC extract that has been vaporized
with a volcano
for example the c-max is going up over a
hundred percent so you're gonna have
psychotic
psychotic psychoactive effects coming
from that THC and the time for maximal
concentration it goes to 70 minutes
instead with Sativex you have a much
more gradient increase on the
concentration it stays around 5 to 10
nanograms per minute and the T max is 60
minutes is a much more slower
way of absorb your THC other
formulations like a CVD self emulsion
that was published by the Atzmon group
in 2017
compared to Sativex itself you can see
how the Green Line is the self emotion
the red line is Sativex you see how you
get higher concentration and a much
faster at a faster time and you have
linearity with the dose in the figure
below you have a dark green which is a
hundred milligrams and you have a light
green which is ten milligrams is the
same one that you have on the top so
this is just a given idea of how
different formulations are going to
affect the absorption of that CVD which
might actually cause a difference in
efficacy this is from the kinetic data
from AP dialects and you can see here in
the table of how plasma concentration
after one single dose reached similar
concentrations of CBD there was no
difference between five milligrams
kilogram per day ten milligram unto
milligram and 20 milligram probably
because you have reached the saturation
level of CVD meaning that you cannot get
higher CVD on your blood
well because it's being metabolized you
can see the metabolite six hydroxy and
seven carboxy cbt how they go up as you
increase the dosing but the active
control in the blood is not gonna be
higher so I'm speaking of this type of
clinical trials actually this
elimination it's I mean we all focus on
how fast can have units are absorb at
how these cannabinoids are being
eliminated or are they building up in
our system and your blood it's also an
important fact that many of these
clinical designs are ignoring when we
consider the last sample is normally
taken at 72 hours in three days after
intake so speaking of it I just wanted
to touch base really briefly on clinical
indications for headaches and I know
it's because this is something that we
hear a lot and we could ask I mean
clinicians researchers alike get asked
by patients right even if in their
families I mean what is camera I mean
will cannabis will help kind of is help
me so there's a lot of former
pharmaceutical problems on cannabis and
cannabinoids but as I say cannabis
because I mean it might be you know we
have high THC strange we have low THC
strains high CBD strain so composition
of cannabis is never it's a genius isn't
even a farmer genius sorry it's actually
easier a genius but what we have
basically agree and it's collected in
this excellent report from the National
Academy of Sciences published in 2017
that I found the others to contribute as
a consultant to have found that we have
conclusive evidence of the clinical
efficacy of cannabis and cannabinoids
for chronic pain in adults 65 percent of
patients that take cannabis for
therapeutic reasons do so for pain
indications normally chronic pain
indications and also for the ability to
reduce the use of opiates prescription
opiates that they're normally taking for
the chronic conditions it's also there's
conclusive evidence for the effects of
cannabis as antiemetics for the
treatment of chemotherapy news and
vomiting and also for improving patient
reported multiple sclerosis a spasticity
so after this I list another series of
indications that the that the report
describes as moderate evidence or now so
the close of evidence and then we'll see
such as improvement short-term sleep
outcomes individuals with chronic issues
like sleep apnea or fibromyalgia chronic
pain and multiple sclerosis so these are
other indications that we have limited
evidence or clinical for clinical
efficacy like increase in appetite
weight loss associated to AIDS and
improving clinical measure multiple
sclerosis society disorders
other indications that we have
anecdotic evidence patients are feeling
relief on these indications but there is
no scientific data to support these
indications for candidates and then we
have limited evidence of a statistical
association with better outcomes on
traumatic brain injury and same for
dementia glaucoma or depressive symptoms
in chronic pain and multiple sclerosis I
really invite the audience to revise up
the list the outcomes of the report
because it's very very interesting and
also you know I pretty so lied about a
lot of conditions for which there is
this analytical promise of cannabis and
cannabinoids but unfortunately we don't
have enough data clinical data yet to
support it I'm a very clinical
researcher so I've been working with
preclinical models most of my life these
means that I work with rats and mice and
we have seen cannabinoids work in in in
animal models for many many different
indications but this is the same case
for many different drugs that are on
development how these drugs will behave
once we take them to the clinic it's a
mystery to us so although there's
promise in animal models we cannot
simply conclude that we're going to see
the same efficacy in a human's so
basically what I wanted to is to set the
frame from what indications we can
actually discuss about taking cannabis
for when patients with chronic pain or
with nausea induced by chemotherapy or
spasticity associated to multiple
sclerosis we know that we have data to
justify the use of cannabis and
cannabinoids you know doctors and
clinicians are going to feel more
comfortable recommending cannabis for
those so what I wanted to see how to
discuss is what approach would it makes
more sense depending on the indication
for the intake of contaminant so this is
a summary of the different ways
so we can put drugs in our organism we
have the gastrointestinal route meaning
through the mouth either by injection or
sublingual through the urine mucosa we
have the internal rod for the liberation
the release of compounds in the
intestine and we have the rectal those
would suffer stories normally are
internal rod means IV when we inject
something directly into a vein the
partner the pulmonary route if when we
hail something the topical ground means
through our steam or mucosa
so basically we have systemic
distribution meaning that cannabinoids
or any drug that we're taking will get
to our blood through the buccal sampling
well oral transdermal or pulmonary route
and these are potential therapeutic
indications that will benefit from a
systemic distribution of cannabis and
cannabinoids and the type of product
that we can think of we want a
sublingual herb you could be a muku
nesaf like putting cannabinoids on on a
patch that you can attach to your to
your oral mucosa a tincture such as
Sativex something that you gotta mean a
picture now normally in ethanol then you
can have sort through your own because
or a trochee sublingual tablet or a
buccal tablet when we think about oral
rod we think about caps syrups oils or
chewing up so we can ingest cannabinoids
and then on the pulmonary we have
inhalation powders and mists and also we
have planned smoking or vaporizing so
some strategies otherwise the following
route this is a titanium pipe that has
been used in clinical studies to
determine the sourcing of tobacco so
there's a company in Canada that has
developed this pellets so you have a
more standardized way of smoking which
is surprising to me because of the other
day probably one of the common the only
agreement that the clinical community
has on cannabis
cannabinoids is that you should not
smoke small caps with you know with
other problems to your health especially
for patients of have already which
Kalfas compromise and it's a way of
administration that allows less control
over the experience although as we saw
before experienced users my actually
control the levels of THC in the blood
by using this route other options are of
course vaporization either or of herbal
cannabis such as the examples and I'm
showing here or vaporizing extracts
which is a practice that has been
extended by the recreational market but
some patients actually benefit from and
the other option will be by conversation
of either powder or a mist containing
candidates which is a challenge even the
the lipophilic nature of canna you know
it's but still there are you know groups
trying to develop products in this line
sublingual of people products such as
sativex have a faster absorption through
the urine because the urine mucosa and
have much less first-pass metabolism
that they don't get degraded in the
liver so much a couple of examples are
Echo pharmaceuticals in the Netherlands
and a california-based company called
Hiroki that develops these tablets you
can read more about this this
formulation of the paper we published in
frontiers of pharmacology last year in
August other different drug another
rocket administration that has been very
popular because I has been developed by
a company in the u.s. is transdermal
administration of CBD this image it
comes from a scientific paper called us
in to a in 2010 in which this academic
group tried to come out
the formulation that will allow the
systemic administration of CVD meaning
CVD get into your blood and then
distribute throughout your body through
the skin through the skin you see the
series of excipient the this exceeded
given CVD on beyond the blood of this
animals I don't recall if there were Oh
guinea pigs hairless guinea pigs and the
benefits of having trust their
negativity absorption will be to reduce
the incidence of gastroduodenal issues
and also reduce a patek first-pass
metabolism directory interaction in the
liver and also avoid the conversion of
CBD to THC in the stomach which is still
controversial I think right now there's
like three or four groups that have this
does have describe the conversion in the
acidic environment of the of the stomach
from Savini to THC that would be
technically something that one could
avoid with this route of administration
however I think this conversion in vivo
remains still controversial this
academic discovery has been developed by
the pharmaceutical companies in Nerva
which has already two products in
development even in preclinical trials
and clinical trials with you know
different outcome different different
success other routes of administration
that are not necessarily systemic but
more local could be rectal vaginal
intranasal and ophthalmic so all these
main causes will allow for THC and CBD
to get to the blood but will also have a
local effect so rectally we can think of
inflammatory bowel diseases people like
our patients or my have pain or
inflammation located in the party
you know Oregon or area with the body
this case the the Colin could benefit
from suppositories or enemas or gels
rather than by a just insulted by mouth
saying goes with this malaria and the
mitosis other diseases from the Adam a
trio in women intranasal of course will
be a route of administration that allows
CVD RTC to get to the blood but also
could be used for lethal diseases such
as brain that Remini disorder in
neurological effects shows migraine
always with a you know a local vocalize
distribution and also of talvik through
the the cornea the eyes because drugs
can also get to the blood but also will
be aligned with some potential
indications for cannabinoids such as
reducing the intraocular pressure in
glaucoma the formulation in this case
could be eyedrops
for example so these are some examples
from the recreation of market that gives
us an idea of what you know either a
Journal of lie or suppository containing
CVD or THC will look like and that
there's actually patients looking after
this presentation and use of them for
some of these indications what about
internal administration of CBD the same
group that did the transdermal brought
us some data about the absorption of THC
and CBD through this route of
administration and this is an example I
submit this company comes from Colorado
now you know how we can successfully
administer THC or CBD depending on the
the parameters that we want to play with
in this case information administration
will be a fast way
of absorbing cannabinoids that for
indication that maybe cannot we won two
hours for an onset of action and then at
the second time won't be preferred for
chronic treatments in which we need to
maintain the concentration in the blood
within the synthetic range the more
innovative that we are the more
innovation that we seem in the area of
cannabinoid pharmacology excuse me
comes with the development of nano
carriers for cannabinoids now for
cannabinoids and other natural compounds
this is a very nice review by Conte and
colleagues in which they revise what
kind of techniques we have to make
little vehicles for all these active
molecules to to get to the places where
they have to be able to go in a general
these molecules especially in the in the
case of vital cannabinoids they're very
difficult to dissolve in water and
therefore they're not very friendly or
they don't match with biological
environments because at the end of a
thirty percent water so there are many
things that we cannot do on phyto
cannabinoids as we know them for example
you know we know that oil and water do
not mix so it's hard to think about what
based formulation for these guys however
there are ready companies and groups
that are trying to challenge the
solubility of cannabinoids in water
through some of these techniques this
could also this could allow for a many
for a range of applications for
cannabinoids because I mean we should
hurry the news about why not making beer
right with cannabis for the recreational
market but at the other day if we can
put THC and CBD in an IV administration
we can have we can put them in a series
that we can inject intradermally or each
article
then we will reduce the side effects
that are associated to cannabinoids
because we will confine them in a
particular space within the body that we
will maximize the efficiency and bring
down the adverse effects and of course
at the other day why not we will be able
to enjoy cannabis flavor soda that's you
know what appeals to you so basically
with these structures are there has been
some academic work and it has been also
some industry work that in which for
which data is not really available my
impression is that there's a lot of CVD
water out there that has no CBD at all
but that is my understanding so far so I
mean what I'm trying to the message of
trying to send is that this is
technically feasible we have done it for
other things that do not dissolve in
water that are not cannabinoids so
Konami this wouldn't be I mean they're
challenging but we could find a solution
for this but definitely there's a level
of technological refine this that is
required to do so so basically the
Australia strategies that we have follow
is making nanoparticles either from
polymers so for other lipids in which we
can load cannabinoids and we have seen
how you know formulated in this way in
cannabinoids increasing their efficacy
the other day remains a challenge to see
if we can reduce side effects but it
seems that it will allow control over
the release of this can now we know it's
both in a space and time meaning that we
can have control release formulation so
we don't need that they may intake but a
weekly intake for example or
cannabinoids or side control
formulations may be that even if you
adjust this type of formulation of
cannabinoid it will be released only in
the place where it is required thus
reducing the amount of side effects that
might have reactions
of this formulation could be topical for
a cosmetic or pajamas infection such as
you know dermatitis or eczema you will
have on the presentation of a cream or a
yellow we could have intruder Mick
it will be still a local distribution we
could do this by objective intradermally
or by coming up with formulations that
were able to penetrate the term is the
epidermis into the dermis and there is
where the site of action for these
molecules it's found in many places that
where you have your hair follicles
that's where you have your nerve
terminals and that's a way in which we
can technically affair theoretically
increase the efficacy of these compounds
finally the inch articular
administration we know that cannabinoids
have a lot of their pinnacle promise for
inflammation joint diseases so being
able to place these molecules right in
the place where they are needed will
probably unlikely increase their
efficacy also so this is this was this
is the end of my presentation I really
wanted to send this message about the
education about it I think it's worth
thinking that there are many options for
patients and for recreational users 2:11
smoking and depending on the goal of our
practice with cannabis some of it would
be preferred over others what we are
maybe miss it as a little bit of
Education and knowledge for all the
users to have you know a safer and more
effective use of your cannabis on
cannabinoids
Thank You dr. Marino seance for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank laberd's for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June 28th to
2019 and as a final reminder our speaker
will follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we'll see
you next time bye